[Música]
Hablamos ahora de economía en directo
América de France 24 Daniela Blandón ya
con nosotros en el estudio de Dani buena
mañana de jueves hablamos de los varios
bancos centrales de todo el mundo porque
muchos siguieron los pasos de la reserva
Federal de Estados Unidos que ayer subió
las tasas de interés pero otros no lo
hicieron así es Raúl muy buenos días
Pues fue noticia Ayer todo el día
económica la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos como lo esperaba al mercado
aumentó su tasa de intervención por
quinta vez en el año tercera consecutiva
en un intento por controlar la inflación
y es muy posible que siga por este
camino hasta 2023 solamente Hoy le voy a
decir Quiénes hicieron lo mismo El Banco
Central de Inglaterra en su sexto
movimiento seguido El Banco Central de
Suiza que llevó a cabo su mayor subida
de la historia y puso fin a varios años
de tasas negativas Taiwán e Indonesia
siguieron también estos mismos pasos
como también el territorio de Hong Kong
filipinas y Noruega por mencionar
solamente algunos pero también Ustedes
prefieren frenar esa estrategia como
Brasil que mantuvo sus tasas de interés
Después de 12 meses consecutivos de
subidas y otros que mantienen una
política a poco ortodoxa que es el caso
de Japón que ha dado contra la corriente
y ha dejado estas tasas estables
escuchemos por qué
la economía de Japón Todavía está en
medio de la recuperación de los efectos
de la pandemia además el aumento de los
precios de las materias primas impulsado
por la crisis de Ucrania está empeorando
los términos de intercambio de Japón lo
que conduce a una salida de ingresos al
exterior lastrando a la economía dadas
estas circunstancias es necesario apoyar
la economía y asegurar que alcancemos
nuestra meta de inflación de manera
estable sostenida y acompañada de un
crecimiento de los salarios por lo tanto
es conveniente mantener nuestra política
monetaria expansiva política monetaria
expansiva esta zona en las declaraciones
del gobernador del Banco Central de
Japón pero no se me asuste le va a
explicar rápidamente Qué es subir la
demanda para reactivar la economía con
tasas baja lo que hacían en pandemia y
lo contrario a la política restrictiva
que es la que está haciendo el banco de
Central de Estados Unidos Dani y vamos a
Reino Unido porque ya en ese territorio
se puede hacer fracking se podrá ser
fracking bueno el gobierno
levantó formalmente este jueves una
moratoria sobre esta actividad que ha
estado vigente desde 2019 después de que
el regulador de la industria dijera que
no era posible predecir la magnitud de
los terremotos que podría desencadenar
esta actividad la fracturación
hidráulica de Raúl es una fracturación
que se hace de las rocas para obtener
gastes quisto de una forma de
explotación petrolera no convencional y
pese a tener gran éxito en países como
Estados Unidos también ha levantado
preocupaciones entre los ambientalistas
incluidos los de Gran Bretaña el
ministro de negocios y de energía Jacob
Reason defendió que en crisis
energéticas como la actual se deben
explorar todas las fuentes de recursos
disponibles como una prioridad absoluta
Así es Dani vamos ahora a la Unión
Europea porque a prueba a preparar
nuevas sanciones contra Rusia esto por
supuesto por invasión a Ucrania Así es
los 27 ministros de relaciones
exteriores del bloque comunitario están
en Nueva para la reunión anual de
líderes mundiales de Naciones Unidas y
en ese contexto acordaron que van a
lanzar nuevas sanciones contra Rusia y
aumentar las entregas de armas aquí
después de que el presidente Vladimir
Putin ordenará la gran primera
movilización de fuerzas desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial esto para combatir en
Ucrania el anuncio lo hizo el jefe de la
diplomacia europea Yo sé yo soy borrell
y se trataría del octavo paquete de
sanciones contra el kremlin y esta vez
apuntaría nuevos sectores como el
Tecnológico A mediados de octubre va a
haber una nueva reunión formal de
cancilleres para darle forma a esta
iniciativa y en otras noticias a Donald
Trump y tres de sus hijos Dani y los
demandaron por un fraude fiscal sí Raúl
el miércoles la fiscal general de Nueva
York en Leticia James lanzó una demanda
civil contra el expresidente y sus tres
hijos de que los acusa de toda una
década de mentiras financieras a bancos
y autoridades para obtener tratos
favorables en sus salva Santana nos
amplía
más problemas legales para Donald Trump
y también para su familia después de que
la fiscal general de Nueva York Leticia
James presentara una demanda civil por
sobrevalorar sus activos y patrimonio
exigimos a Trump y a su organización que
se deshagan de los beneficios
financieros obtenidos a través de las
prácticas fraudulentas persistentes
estimados en al menos 250 millones de
dólares
según la fiscalía Donald Trump y la
empresa Trump organization infló Su
riqueza en miles de millones para
obtener condiciones más favorables para
sus transacciones como tasas de interés
más bajas y seguros más baratos una
denuncia además de 200 páginas en la que
también figuran tres hijos de Trump
Donald Trump Junior Eric Trump e ivanka
Trump así como los ejecutivos de la
empresa acusaciones que Trump ha negado
de plano acusando a la fiscal negra
neoclasicismo otra casa de brujas por
parte de una fiscal general racista
letillas James que fracasó en su carrera
para gobernadora obteniendo un apoyo
casi nulo del público este es uno de los
muchos entramados legales que se
amontonan sobre su figura como la
investigación penal a por su acción
contra las elecciones presidenciales del
2020 o la investigación Federal sobre la
posesión de registros presidenciales
clasificados la fiscal James Lleva más
de tres años investigando la empresa de
Trump y cuenta con puentes cercanas al
expresidente
Fue llamado a testificar el 10 de agosto
cuando se acogió más de 400 veces a su
derecho de no autoincriminarse negando
todos los cargos Daniela cifra al día
los 100.000 vehículos Raúl que va a
dejar de producir Toyota en octubre esto
debido a la crisis mundial de chips
quiere decir que el mayor fabricante de
vehículos del mundo reducirá su
producción en alrededor de un 10% frente
a los 900.000 que ensambla normalmente
cada mes y hablando de carros y tengo
tiempo le voy a dar otra noticia de
carros mire los vehículos que más se
roban en Estados Unidos son los de las
marcas asiáticas Hyundai y Kia esto
según estadísticas recopiladas entre
2015 y 2019 por el instituto de datos de
pérdidas en carreteras Ellos dicen que
muchos de esos coches no tienen
inmovilizadores eléctricos de motor que
normalmente lo que hacen es impedir el
encendido cuando detectan que se está
produciendo un robo esta característica
es estándar en casi todos los vehículos
fabricados por otras empresas ahora las
compañías se defendieron diciendo que no
que tranquilos ya comenzaron a poner
estos inmovilizadores de motor desde el
año pasado Bueno vamos a ver si no se
roban más esta marca de carros y como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica más adelante más